welcome to this video radu lua from
Romania okay the Kings Indian no okay I
just wanted to do something a bit
different so a modern type of defense
how very early age three hmm how to play
here maybe maybe I can do something
irregular attacking the center quickly
with e five I might take a for very dull
play okay come on just just develop if
you place d5 I can just retreat if I
want to be 80 he plays it a very simple
fashion i think i should i should put
something in the center right pawn takes
Knight x maybe night eggs
yeah if it takes now if it all takes
everything it really is a little bit
dull mmm yeah but ok I don't think I
have any problem whatsoever so better
start to play for win from an equal
position that from the worst position
hoorah I immediately takes ok I am maybe
trying to do something with the pin but
i have c 6 anyway 95 was a is a possible
idea ok i have roop d4 here maybe double
attacking
now I want him to go to d3 so that I
have Bishop e6 again getting my bishop
to an active square yeah here yeah I
guess it's better to go to d8 back to
the age because g7 is the place for a
night 97 yeah maybe start with this I'd
like to play 97 and Bishop c5 maybe I
can also could have maybe gone for like
h5 King h7 bishop age 6 but that's I ok
maybe night a 4 s.s idea no but I have
be 594 I have b5 this tactic due to the
hanging rook on the FR so this is not
not in any way a problem
a takes a takes you cannot take p6
because the root gangs and I castles ok
now Bishop c5 finally up all night be 64
total doll 44 total doll darkness this
is a word that's really really boring
but maybe I can take and play night c5
by the way maybe this instilled some
life into the position yeah I'm
attacking be three now and he does not
want to take on c5 I guess giving me the
bishop pair ok this is still not that
easy what really wants to trade
everything ok it's not not any any
choice iam um ok so if i take now on d3
i have the bishop am is there any better
moves like night a4 or something
probably and probably not let's just
take it so the night will move to be six
that has no square what was it seven so
i probably want to prevent night c7
probably should be should be three SS my
it's not helping much ok yeah at least
the night this is a real problem peace
i'm going to switch or activate the king
should be 62 c seven but this is at the
end also miss placing pieces
my long really if he just doesn't do
anything I go all the way to be seven
then Knight b6 Bishop c7 and it is
trapped this is the the simple idea and
maybe this is okay so Bishop c7 is what
he wants to do King e7 Bishop c7 wait
still trapped I didn't think about that
move ahead stupid but the night's still
is not in a in a good spot threatening
king d 7 again dropping it
this move is covering a six so King d7
night goes to a 8
time warning hmm yeah tough i only i
would like to really calculate this but
hard to do with the limited time his
night is obviously totally stranded so
probably there is something that gives
me killing something substantial but i
couldn't really find it now Bishop c5
king dr cannot cannot go with them okay
it's it's still nice for me the move
like 95 leaves a very weak pawn on d5
and after takes Bishop takes I'm
threatening King d66 almost then he's
got then he really has 95 but okay it's
not easy for him to play this position
his pieces are paralyzed that's not
leading to much really how do I win this
is their way to minute and I'll I 25 no
stupid stupid stupid no the bloody time
check for Bishop age three check check
invasión time
white resign yeah at the end it fell
apart but difficult stuff I mean I
cannot believe I'm not winning with the
night on a ATM but it's still somewhat
tricky how to do it c5 is actually the
comp move but yeah it does not it's not
like the computer is giving like minus 3
some way to trap the night maybe it's
simply not possible I'd like to check if
at which point this end game starts to
be a be winning for black ok here we are
already talking about a big echium yeah
this the bishop is just near this pawn
and after g3 black windsor this is the
the typical the typical motif that will
decide the game ok and I can invade now
whether it was rather than mice yeah I
hope you enjoyed this end game thanks
for watching